rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message fail
your way to success over to you Michelle
Obama this is what I tell my daughters
every day do not be afraid to fail
because that often times is the thing
that keeps us as women and girls back
because we think we have to be right and
we think we have to be perfect we think
that we can't stumble and the only way
you succeed in life the only way you
learn is by failing it's not the failure
it's what you do after you fail you know
do you let it eat you up do you quit do
you give up or do you let it bolster you
does it serve as as the challenge in
your mind to do more to take some risks
to step outside of your comfort zone if
you want to succeed then you need to
adjust how you see failure failure is
going to happen if you look at the most
successful people in the world we've
studied them where in the book they're
all over the channel they failed the
most the most successful person and you
look up to these like wow that person is
so successful I can't believe it
they have failed way more than you even
try not everything works out most of the
series that I put out on this channel
don't work out we test constantly and
most of them never go anywhere they just
don't get enough traction this is an
experiment you failed we move on to the
next one we have failed more than most
people even try and that's why we
succeed and that's a consistent habit
around people who are winning they win
because they tried so many other things
and a certain percentage make their way
through and most people are so afraid to
fail but they don't even try and that's
the biggest failure of all they're so
afraid of it not work
but not being the big hit but they just
sit on their idea and then they watch
somebody else make tons of money you
have a huge impact from it get it out
there may not be the biggest version of
what you're trying to do but start start
small build momentum see if you still
even like this thing or not see if you
can get some people interested in their
line and expect to fail failure is not
the enemy
failure is normal failure is welcomed
right you're gonna learn from it you're
gonna build on it you're gonna make it
better if you are not feeling if you're
winning every time think about it like
if you're winning every time
everything you touch wins that means
you're playing a tiny game it means
you're racing against three-year-olds
great congratulations you want every
single race because you're running
against three-year-olds if you want to
be the best you want to have an impact
you want to make your business a success
you want to make money you want to reach
people you didn't have to race against
people who are a little more skilled and
talented you're gonna have to risk
losing you're not gonna win every race
but the good news is you don't have to
you don't have to win every race to
succeed you just have to win one you can
run a hundred races you just need to win
one and then they call you an overnight
success so just adjust your view of
failure expect things to pay out it's
not like I'm cheering for it to fail but
I expect most things that I touch to
fail that's okay that's normal
that's what happens if you're the person
who's just so afraid to fail that you
don't try anything then you need this
video and these kinds of videos and
resources more than anybody you need to
surround yourself with people with ideas
with resources whether it's a videos
whether it's the book something else
where people are talking about failure
we are hanging around successful ideas
because anybody who's saying not to try
something because it may not work out
that's that's a small thinking person if
somebody's telling you that like don't
try this because it may not work out I
would challenge you to look at their
life look at their accomplishments look
at what they're doing and then guarantee
you they're playing small in their life
and that's not something that you want
to emulate so you need to change your
environment you got to change what
you're feeding into this because the
more that you are accepting that line of
thinking the more you just gonna stay
where you are
tomorrow you're never gonna go out and
build this thing the more you're just
gonna sit in your
couch and be a dreamer with great dreams
with amazing dreams that could have a
huge impact that you never actually take
any action on because you're too afraid
to fail so if that's you I challenge you
to start get into that habit surround
yourself with those people you know you
don't have Michelle Obama in your life
that's okay
the good news is Michelle Obama is a
pretty public person if this message
resonated with you you can put in her
name as a YouTube alert and get updates
every time she makes a new video if you
like my message you can subscribe to the
channel those three videos that come out
every day there's enough content there
to start to shift your mindset the key
is making that consistent the key is
consuming that on a daily basis so you
start to ship and you start to change
because this one video is not enough
because doing something once is not
enough you are what you consistently do
you are who you consistently hang around
with you or you consistently believe he
is consistently so what are you
consistently doing and how is that view
of failure preventing you from doing so
the question today today is I'm curious
what is the thing that you're afraid of
feeling you know you have a big dream
you have a big ideas a new project you
unlock it you're afraid what is that
thing I want I want to help release that
fear that it's normal that it's okay
leave it down in the comments below
share we believe nation we got your back
I want to see what you have I also want
to give a quick shout out to me Jean the
show I think you saw what you're picking
up a cup of my book you're one word
really really really means a lot to me
and I hope you enjoy me so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
and I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
I think that the people that are on that
are discovering how to unleash their
greatness are people who have the mental
resiliency and the courage to face
failure that you will fail your way to
greatness that most people allow their
fear of failure
80% allow their fear of failure talk--we
their desire to succeed when you're
willing to fail again and again and
again when you make up your mind to
become unstoppable when you make up your
mind to become a no matter what person
then that will then give birth to a part
of yourself that you don't know right
now you know so often people are
consumed with fear the fear of judgement
that's a huge one the fear of failure
what happens if it doesn't work the fear
of success what happens if it does work
and people see me like they really see
me for who I am what happens if I get
hurt in a relationship like there's so
many what is but what happens when you
what if yourself all over yourself you
never think about the what if it works
what if what if it has just a just as
much chance at working as it doesn't not
working and what if you redefine what we
call failure and in my language I love
it in the book abundance now that I
wrote and many of you have read it I
talked about you can fail all day long
just fail forward the only distinction
between a bunch of really successful
individuals and a bunch of individuals
really wanting success is that the
successful individuals we're willing to
fail and they did fail they just failed
forward some of my best lessons are born
out of my failures literally to this day
and my failures these days cost six
figures or more but I'm willing to do
that because I want the lesson or the
outcome and if you allow a failure to
feed your futures what I call feeding
your future meaning what are the two
things that I did really well and what's
the one area that I can improve upon or
what's the three things I did really
well and what are the two areas that I
could improve
and then take those two things and pull
those that lesson forward or take the
three things that you did well and make
sure you don't lose those to me the
tragedy the tragedy of when something
doesn't go the way you thought is when
you only beat yourself up from it you
never ever look at what did I do well
and where can I improve
there's always success in failure you
just have to know where to look for it
and that means that's a learning moment
so you say Evie Vega is success in
learning if you know how to know exactly
you just have to look for it because
then you use that again and you make
sure you don't make that mistake again
or don't allow that mistake to happen so
your goal is to then just because it
didn't work out the way you wanted to
take that knowledge take those learnings
and reapply it to a new you know a new
direction and therefore you're gonna get
better no one's you know I think you've
had I've had failure and it takes years
of building up that kind of thick skin
around you but that's what it means to
be resilient you just get up and you
keep going and you can and I can't tell
you there's been times when I just sat
there I was like oh the world is gonna
be over and then you know what you just
look at it and you think about it and
you have to project yourself not today
but to project yourself into the future
what could I do in the future if you
keep looking ahead everybody fails
you're not the only one everybody does
just get over it keep going raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
values is that we believe that people
with passion
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details